《红楼梦》的结局是什么样的?立来的《红学家》分析这个问题,都绕不过《红楼梦》第一回。也就是《真事影》、《梦幻》、《失通》林、《家语》、《存》、《封城》、《怀歸》秀。在这一张墨尾,博足道人唱了一首好聊歌。真事影对这首好聊歌进行了一番诸节。这番诸节里就暗含了一些结局的内容。
皮书人之眼摘还在旁边进行了解释,把每句话对应了谁谁谁的结局都披在一边。但就是这些披玉引发了一些争议。
这番争议初在《家语本》石头记身上。据说这套《家语本》最初是流泉服的收藏,后来让胡适买下来,只披的很多《披玉》都是来自《家语本》,所以它的价值是非常高的。
但有一些学者对《家语本》里真事影诸节好聊歌的相关披玉产生的质疑,认为这些披玉是靠不住的。
比如吴氏昌先生,他曾转文《残本指披》石头记的《底本》及其年代,里面就详续论述了《家语本》披玉的不靠谱。
比如,《真事影诸节》里说,说什么知证农,反正相,如何两遍又成双。
《家语本》在这句话旁边披了一句,《待遇》《秦文》一干人,这完全是错误的。
胡氏昌就点出来说,《待遇》和《秦文》他们是大官原理最短命的两个美人。
《秦文》在《八十回》前以死,不到二十岁。
《待遇》之死既在原稿中,也不会在《八十回》以后太久,他们二人如何会两遍成双。
《其实家语本》的《披玉》错误不止这一句,还有几句也是错的。
比如,《金销红灯帐底握冤养》,旁边披了一句,《西风》一干人,这也是牛头不对马嘴。
《在比如今满乡》,《一满乡旁边》披了一句,《真语》,《假语》一干人,把《真假》寶玉跟《金营》联在一起,好像是说他们都是贪财鬼,这也是错误的。
所以,胡氏昌先生的质疑是正确的,但这不代表《假训本》的《披玉》是错误的。
为什么这么说,我们今天就来细细拆解一番。
简单来说就是,《披玉》本身是正确的,只是被抄错的地方,这是超书人犯的错误,不能让知眼债来背锅。
我们都知道,《假训本》是典型的过路本,也叫做《疼超本》。
《超书人》根据《草血情》的圆狗进行超路,但《超书人》毕竟不是《草血情》,他不知道真是影的诸节对应的人物是哪个,只能赵胡鲁化飘。
知眼债的《披玉》在意面哪个位置,他就赵抄在哪个位置。
大家可能会觉得奇怪,如果真的是赵折位置抄血,那应该抄的都是对的,怎么会把《披玉》位置搞错呢?
关于这个问题,已经有前人学者给出了答案,那就是《超书人》抄《披玉》是赵折位置抄,但《超证文》就不识了。
而且假训本的《超守》对《红楼梦》一点也不了解,比如诸节内里的《待遇》《情文》一干人,《待遇》的《待遇》的《待遇》被抄成了《待款》的《待》,如果这个《超书人》了解《红楼》就一定不会犯这种低级错误。
把《待遇》的《待遇》的《超》错》在《更成本》里也有,《超守》经常取上半部,把《待遇》的《待》抄成取《待》的《待》,但很明显,《更成本》的《超守》是故意的。
它收为了减化自行,所以它把《待遇》减化之后就一直引用这个《待遇》,读者也知道它是在兼写,不会去叫这个《真》。
假训文把《待遇》的《超》错》完全是因为《超守》人不了解《红楼》人物,将上《超》的时候出新大意,就犯了这种在《红楼》爱好者看来,几乎是低级的错误。
《超守》人把《披语》的位置照着超,但《正文》的字数、《行》数,就没有按照严格的标准疼路,就导致出现了每一行比原稿少一两个字,近而累积成《正文》位置挪移的情况。
根据阳光汉先生的竹字比较,他对《曹雪清》比下的《低本》做出了如下分析。
《低本》中《正文》《顶格》写《美行》二十字,《回钱长批》《第一格》写《美行十九字》。
《假训文》过录时,将办事改为《正文》《顶格》写《美行十八字》。《回钱长批》《第一格》写《美行十七字》。
《假训文》既然比《低本》《美行》少写两个字,累积五行就会多出半行来,累积九行就会多出整整一行来。
这便是这个假训本上,若干测批,措置地位的一个重要原因。
其实不止阳光汉,张爱临在《红罗梦》演,二次想《红罗梦》之,假训文与更成本的年份,也多次提到《假训文》超写的格式问题。
竹君如果感兴趣,可以自行去翻语《红罗梦》演。
《红罗梦》的解证就是这种超法的受害者。
如果我们了解了这种措置,然后通过上面这种分析,把假训本的证文位置进行调整,就会发现一切都变得通顺了。
待遇《秦文》一干人,对应的证文变成了《昨日黄土龙头堆白骨》,表明《带秦两人》早早就去世了。
保育《香云》一干人,对应的证文变成了《如何两病又成双》,表明保采和《香云》最后中老。
《王西风》一干人,对应的证文则变成了《鸡满香》一满香,暗示《王西风》一生贪财,还挪勇越前对外放态。
《珍玉》假于《一干人》对应的证文,恰好是《展演起盖人街帮》,表明《珍家假家》被抄家之后,珍宝玉和《假宝玉》都过了很长的苦日子。
包括《智验摘》后文还说《假宝玉》,寒冬叶酸鸡血液为破粘,跟这一句《展演起盖人街帮》也是对应的。
这就足可见,上述阳光汉先生的分析是有意应道理的。
之所以把这个问题单独拎出来跟大家聊,是因为我最近在看一些红龙梦的书籍,
发现很多版本还是按照《假训本》来进行披语位置的标注。
比如我手头上的《北京联合出版社》的《红龙梦》,以及昨天我刚刚录《开箱视频》发布的《上海古吉出版社》新出的《红龙梦》指批会教本。
他们严格按照《手超本》的《披语位置》进行标注。
但《不知情》的读者可能就会误读,不知道这些《披语》位置标错了。
所以《不红军》再次特别提醒一番。
那这就是今天的视频的全部内容了,如果大家喜欢我的解读,
希望多多点赞收藏,我们下个视频再见。